this is the answer that was a whole
bunch of nothing right pure filler yeah
um nothing progressed at all what a
disappointment
the flashback story this is some bedtime
story she told Stephen yeah come on
something something love
yeah the answers are always loved else
is really fuckin good I like fuchsia
phobia my future phobic side just can't
do you know this is a liberation for me
yeah though this is lack of a better
term if it's the perfect term what a
lovely episode it was just a nice day
was just darling just darling
it really felt like yeah yeah made me a
warm and fuzzy like a right there it
felt like I have a genuine like romantic
fairy tale like in all the best ways not
like the really lame man this really
sucks way um like even the layout
fucking gorgeous those simple shall we
we started we started like just quoting
like Sleeping Beauty because like it
totally looks like the background art
from Sullivan yeah when they're in the
forest yeah particularly when there are
more is and there's and really swinging
around that was very this was definitely
their like give us an Academy Award emmy
type of like artsy film kind of episode
like it was really artistic the
artisanal of the layout that a fucking
of blue diamond i love the design of
that character cheese can shadow the
sizes work cuz we were just talking i'm
like cuz i would totally want to be one
of those giant gems like blue diamond or
like where i'm like 80 feet tall or
whatever i'm just curious like what are
they just extra fancy is that i didn't
just different stones different people i
guess cuz I'm just like I have like I
took one her I'm like badass was its uh
and the Rose is the leader of the
rebellion and she's very tall and yeah
which I did they establish before she
was the leader of the rebellion we knew
she was a part of I don't know if we
know she was the leader I don't know if
I got the
I knew she was a major player in it um
and what's the helper tube like by the
way how what was that lapis I couldn't
it looked kind of like yeah I could as
she had her eyes closed - so I wasn't
sure - lapis was serving them uh maybe I
don't know um but I feel like there's
more that's not being said about how
this society is divided up but we got
nobody big piece of it right here with
the way it's just like you fused
abomination oh why because there were
two different gems that makes more sense
now cuz that I was always wanted cuz
it's like well seems like they fusing
it's okay but it's cuz they're in it to
longer side so they're two different
gems but also it also messed up the
whole like I guess the rebellion was
supposed to fall or something if you
know what a fun the more I'm thinking
about this just what a fun set up that
they live in a world where it's supposed
to be two of the same gems but two that
are uh different is the abomination you
know and it's an emotion looks like an
all-gay society and the ones that are
different those are the Hellcats hetero
what's up oh that's Star Trek The Next
Generation - the great episode along
similar wise there's obviously a
metaphor for that and like it just
they've reported out how ridiculous it
is because this verse is just like but
like this feels normal it's like so you
engage in hetero that's that's weird
that's really really like they couldn't
wrap their heads of Allah yeah it's
almost like when you think about it like
it almost should be the other way
because it's like we would have better
understanding but we couldn't procreate
so when you put yourself in somebody
else's shoes you realize how ridiculous
it is yeah well that's why I mean like
some people like the reactions to like
idea of Zootopia were like you know did
a mostly you know good and stuff like
that uh but like when somebody is like
well what you want for an analogy of
prejudice that's interesting and do and
sound like this I really like this a
little more I still get a Cesar Toby um
it's good it's fine um but when I think
like 98% like you know like or 99 I
think it said now I know it's like some
people are just saying it does he okay
that 98 is still you really
you're gonna have 99% and 40% of those
could is could be like that's alright
okay there's a difference between that
like this is the greatest movie ever
made oh but I'd still listen to no
theatres when it isn't Nursing is
phenomenal then and the forty percent
the forty percent say it's okay none of
them said it's okay but now I'm not
recommending it they're still really
least some of it so it depends on how
rotten tomatos movies that up because
sometimes I've read reviews where I'm
just like this seemed mostly negative
but they put it in just a positive
enough category to give it up I'm like
sure it's like oh but no I mean to me
this is just so imaginative and so
beautifully laid out and just so rich in
character and story and complex but
simple I mean to me it's just it's got
kind of everything to and I so want to
try her hair I mean that looks like
cotton candy
sissy even though I really I did my
chest cotton candy here even the layout
was both like so simple but so
complicated just these very simple
shapes the people like you know where
the simple shades and with the dot eyes
you can see through them and stuff but
like the colors and the shading and just
the various types I mean it's just it's
such a good book and the twist because
there is no true thing in history then
when you decide to be racist prejudice
asshole and exclude people how it blows
up in your fucking face cuz that that
was the greatest one of the greatest
lessons in this episodes whether like
Australia you can't do this and what
happens basically the good now garnet
goes meets up with the fucking rebellion
and how do they treat her they're like
no it's okay like you're important to us
that's so cause ever seen this before
yeah I got like whoa so he will treat
you like you know a real person and all
is it now you got garnet out of the same
the frickin Nazis did the same thing
they chased half their scientists up
they come working for us suck it
yeah bit oh it's just when you exclude
people it blows up in your face
well it's so funny how much we keep
repeating that I mean it's like oh god
yeah well that's why I fucking hate like
you know that we always had to keep
seeing these stories of like you know
hey
no prejudice is bad everything cuz it's
like god dammit we still need this shit
because you think it would be common
several yeah that's 20% like it does not
seem complicated it seems like common
sense and it's just not catching out
with some people it's catching out a lot
we look at like tolerance of like you
know history and stuff like that I mean
we have gotten a lot of that part of the
problem now we have the reactionary
movement of Tolerance makes me afraid
I'm a white man afraid of change I can't
deal with it
yeah I mean it's one of those things
where it's like and there I mean it's
yeah it's just so strange I mean you
always think like you know yeah like
we've really come a long way and I still
think we have I mean compared to history
and everything but it's like oh sure
when you see just how many there are of
like the you know people are just like
no I want to be in this box I don't want
anything different I just want this one
thing and you're wrong for wanting
something different it's like oh it's
not the white wall it's nice yeah I mean
it is one of those things I mean it's I
mean and that does go to like it not
just race and gender and culture and all
that stuff I mean it's just it's a
limiting mindset altogether
oh I might you know page everything
makes you dumber that's what I've never
liked and only know it makes you dumber
and my problem with that well we've come
a long way as if that's like we can stop
now we're done we've achieved perfection
obviously like I hate that argument like
well we've come a long way as if like
okay sure every single fucking
generation sends Adam and Eve or Adam
and Steve or Eva and Eve or hue like
ever since the dawn of time every
generation has said that like I'm sure
in the 1600s well we've come a long way
I mean we're using leeches now we used
to just like chop off both your arms and
pray to God that that would work but you
know we've got leeches so if we can stop
now with cuz we've got leeches we don't
need modern science we can stop we've
come a long way
oh yes yeah what the fuck does that even
mean it was just a cheap excuse to be
like oh well because it's better now
than it was we don't ever even have to
think about this again and we could just
stop
no I'm kind of glad we acknowledge how
far we come because I think if not you
never appreciated that change is
happening know you can appreciate it but
it never no no but it never no but you
know there's people I appreciate it no
it never goes like no no come on you're
you see nothing where nothing is here
nine times out of ten when somebody's
like yeah but we've come a long way
normally its with the mindset that like
and we're we're okay we're done like
it's really my long way let's see how
much more we can keep going yeah very
rarely though does it ever go that way
it's more like we've come a long way so
we're good how many politics politicians
do that well we've come a long way so
like we're we're good I don't I don't
see races I only see grey everywhere I'm
actually colorblind like literally I am
like a dog why it's it's like no shut up
um but no it is something wears out oh
it's interesting and probably everybody
that's you know live long enough
probably I mean everyone that life time
is gonna see change happen you know for
anything and everything really you know
is whether it's for the better for the
worse they're always going to see change
happen and I think that's that's why
that mindset of know you want to be this
one thing or the world has to be this
one thing it's just not always at
limiting its
you know gonna hurt your survival and
you're not gonna thrive because that's
how you don't thrive you stick to one
thing and you're not open to the options
you it's it's a survival tactic that
doesn't allow you to survive you know
you have to go outside the cave um and I
think that's what this episode is me
doing like yeah how I work out for the
meth end yeah that's why it's called the
dark ages
um so I think it's one of those things
where it's like this is a nice episode
that's already sort of hammering in what
we know the message is but from I don't
know from a very interesting kind of
fairy tale ish point of view where I get
sucked into the characters I get sucked
into the romance honestly I really like
romance if it's done well um you know
and I hate a lot of romantic comedies
and stuff some people think oh you hate
romance it's like well I love romance if
it's done really well same thing with
scary movies I so rarely see a scary
movie that's actually scary so people
think I hate scary films no I love them
I just see so
few good ones uh and I felt like this
really tried films that are trying to be
scary but aren't it's one of those
things where it's like I like how it's
both very simple very complicated at the
same time you know it's actually almost
afraid I wouldn't be able to follow the
story cuz they're talking about the
rebellion and the seven stones in far up
and I'm like oh I hope this oh if I
could be a test later by five thousand
years ago this sounds like a Scientology
backstory well we're all gonna go back
to gyms I mean we all know that that's
coming out it's it's in Dianetics but I
saw them battlefield everything um but
yeah so I really like the way this was
Leia I love the way I love how simple
was I love how there's still complex
elements to it and just I really think
the layout especially stop that this
isn't my cell phone's over there I know
I am oh but at the layout especially I
think has sums up the episode where it's
both very simple but you know has very
complex elements in terms of like the
color and the shading and the layout but
it's still based a very simple idea and
I love that I think those just such a
good combination of that it seemed again
this episode seems all about combining
things and so you have these very simple
shapes but these very complex colors and
shades uh but it's in everywhere that's
what I like about if it's also a bedtime
story too and I just think this is what
lady in the water wants to be you know I
think this is all I wanted to do oh my
god fuck yeah
like this is what it should have been
like this yeah no I wouldn't have even I
wouldn't even thought of that but I've
liked it lady in the water been this I
would've been like watch how he still
would have ruined it what about a Steven
would've been played by Paul Giamatti
huh yeah tell me more about it
mmm crystal gems mmm
but garnet would be played by Jeff
Goldblum just because or the hotdogs guy
save the earth save the world so um yeah
I think what else is fi but did you like
crystal gems but but it's also setting
up that there's no to the story to
Mark's point like Mark Wahlberg are good
it totally be peridot you want to
destroy the world
what no
oh I really like how it's sitting up
more like there's still mystery it's not
like all the answers either it's just
enough setup that you're getting more
from this is what cuz I just watched
three the reboot of x-files which
actually that was was decent the middle
episodes are really legitimately awesome
and then the bookended ones are kind of
like yeah but the way in which more shit
happened in six episodes then over nine
seasons like this is what x-files should
have been where it's like you review
pieces of these mysteries as you go on
but I don't feel like I'm being dicked
around here which is what x-files did to
me and also I doesn't feel like I feel
like I'm getting yeah I'm not getting
lectured I'm getting pieces of
information there's still mystery cuz I
don't need all the answers I gotta come
from the group that's it's like there's
somebody but with oh wait after
everything on question I don't need that
but answer some questions you can leave
some mystery like this shows doing it
perfectly yeah really
um and it's it's rare I see that like so
many times ever we get like a fucking
lost or you know or the x-files there's
like nine seasons and then I forget even
movies uh you know we always go back to
like Jupiter ascending and you know the
Shyamalan lady in the water you know uh
shallow movies and you know it's one of
those things where it's like I just feel
like this is this is how you do it right
I mean this is I mean a lot of films are
trying to achieve that or even like
fancy writers I would anyone that wants
to do like the long-term thing I mean I
think this is a very good show to watch
and see what was a better film it's a
whole lot to what complicated ones do
you emphasize this was a better love
story than most ice the most like
romantic comedies I've ever seen in my
entire life
and it did it in 15 minutes yeah I think
about that well again we see that a lot
of the the sapphires are kind of the
same you know they all look alike and
stuff um so I mean I can't we're gained
just these little these little drops
these little nuggets but they they're
delivered at just the right time as just
the right amount of information need and
then just the right amount left out so
you can get attached to what's going on
um I thought was very well done though
the one thing I was kind of curious
about uh did the voice actors seem a
little different to you like the ones of
Sapphire
I'll never forget what a ruby I'm sorry
the rubies were am i honest I don't
remember okay I don't remember
you know they sound easier maybe that
was the intention maybe they're meant to
sound younger because it was supposed to
be a longer go like they almost sounded
like you know like young teenagers or
something like that like they almost
sounded like kids uh but I don't know if
that's the same but it might might just
be remembering it different um I I don't
remember like I I kind of remember their
voices but that one would be like oh
they're completely different
also some uh the last thing I noticed uh
something seemed particularly anime and
there's like the little lines under the
eyes when they're blushing like I
thought that was really really anime and
the look at Rosa's face like the really
there's a lot of anime influence in this
yeah I mean I know they're it's
throughout a lot of it but this one
particularly like with the drawings of
them and their expression it's like
whenever they tend to the go like that
like that just seemed really really well
you I've seen a little little sweat
bubble yeah coming out I yeah there's a
lot of like little anime things like
anime tropes that and interesting to
finding out that garnet was the last one
well okay and not the last one but you
see more and more the connection between
pearl and Rose like that really was it
it was just the two of them and again
you can see a little is that a people
show I can see a little bit more like
sort of a protection everything that hey
like it used to just be the two about
like we were kind of the main thing for
my I will say like I I'm wondering if
the flesh is on more but were they just
the rebellion I'm like is it just those
two or were there others I cuz I thought
I saw them like big battles and swords
that we would have to be more that's
what I'm thinking but I like the way it
was just those two about Rose was a
leader in like promos count like a
bodyguards that's what I think that's
what I got but I just thought it was
weird that it was just those two that
showed up so I'm like I'm assuming
there's more mm-hmm oh but yeah yeah it
was a good strong episode I mean just
that it was really good you were filling
wrappers yeah you know filler even like
the last line of you know what was the
answer love like any other story I'd be
like shut up I
I have the fun allegation Callie oh yeah
any other story I learn would have been
black and like this I'm just like I
adorable Oh what what they did every
Potter in the movie it's like what was
the mark of what wasn't love I'm like no
shut up
out of that five dead five second movie
you did summed it up where he's like
kicking ass and there's like people
blowing up and magic spells and there's
like no longer yeah sure love when
you're fine then firing that a magic
wand at everybody so okay we're gonna
head out to the minute phones ding oh my
god but yeah a really really good
episode and we'll see it the next one
later